The Joe Rogan Experience what is that
lawsuit that I see that's going on right
now the criminal trial with the dude
from the Fugees
what is that do you know that story yeah
he was an FBI a snitch yeah but I think
it's a double agent what because
apparently Tupac said back in the day he
was in the FBI or something like that
well Tupac said he was FBI back in the
day so was nobody listen to Tupac
Tupac's mother was a black panther maybe
they should have listened they should so
he came out he was really an FBI agent
right that's crazy
was he really an FBI agent so here's
who's your rapper Fuji rapper testifies
he met and shared information with the
FBI voluntarily oh who
so Jeff sessions testimony was not
exciting the defense basically said uh
had him describe an official legal
process for considering extraditing guo
at China's request the apparent idea was
to suggest that there was nothing so bad
in pros and Company trying to have guile
sent back to China process testifying in
his own defense told the judge after
Consulting with my attorneys and the
Universe I decided that I will testify
oh he consulted with the universe
I like how people talk like that he's
facing 10 charges including conspiracy
witness tampering and failing to
register as an agent of China wow who
the [__] is cha I mean he's an agent of
China the black dude yes that guy was a
billionaire he was talking about oh uh
okay well I understand profs addressed
his alleged efforts to get the U.S to
extradite Chinese billionaire guo when
Juan GUI in addition he denied acting as
an agent for China
I took it upon myself to report because
I thought the FBI should know he
testified before his trial started the
50 year old artist told Rolling Stone
what benefit would I get trying to break
laws it's not worth it to me I'm like a
pariah now I've got friends who won't
talk to me because they think there's a
satellite in orbit listening to them
to be clear Pros never testified in the
stand that he was an FBI informant his
approach to the FBI to discuss
and three Americans held in China was
completely voluntary if convicted Pros
serves 22 years in prison what do they
think he did that's what I understand
what do they can what do they accusing
him of
okay it says the alleged the veteran
Reimer was the middleman for alleged
crimes including a secret lobbying
campaign to help Malaysian billionaire
Joe Lao uh put pressure on American
Justice officials while White House
officials and White House officials when
his fraud scheme unraveled and to help
the Chinese government secure the return
of a dissident who's living inside the
U.S
I'm not exactly sure what he did I still
don't know what he did I know
everybody's like he's fbis that's what
everybody got a side job but it seems
like then he didn't he wasn't even
informed like he went to the FBI because
he felt like they should know that
which is like Jesus you're opening up
the [__] that goes on see what I'm in my
business see what I say if it's aliens
out there hey if they out there all I
say when you come to our country pay
your taxes
I don't think they're being [__] well I
mean I don't want to pay [__] if I
looked at if what I think about aliens I
think they're monitoring us because
we're highly sophisticated society that
might blow itself up I think that's why
they're here Joe
ain't no [__] negligence here you
don't think so here's a different
explanation in okay bringing the Tupac
thing I just brought up Tupac lyrics
feeling a conspiracy theory after Fuji's
member Pros admits he was an FBI
informant uh the hip-hop world was
shocked when Pras how do you say his
last name
Mitchell Mitchell uh one of the founding
members the legendary group The Fugees
admitted he was an FBI informant during
his Federal conspiracy trial in
Washington DC Pros is accused of
conspiring to make illegal campaign
contributions using foreign funds from a
Malaysian fugitive ciao low who's wanted
also wanted for his role in a massive
corruption Scandal involving billions of
dollars so he got tied up with the wrong
people yeah and then that says somewhere
around here like the a cryptic line from
a song in 96 says something about the
Fugees were trying to do to him oh
speculating that Tupac was aware of
process involvement with the FBI and
that he was expecting him exposing him
as a snitch that's like the internet
runs wild yeah so that's like open to
interpretation
not a bad uh side gear if you come with
health care
side gig working for the FBI those
normal Health Care they seem to all go
to jail anyway
pretty much yeah those FBI informants it
seems like a lot of those guys wind up
going to jail anyway data uh uh what is
it when they protect you for the rest of
your life oh witness protection yeah
that's real fun yeah you gotta live in
the middle of nowhere
with a fake name
just stay at home just let me get killed
I just got to go to one more Club better
explanation maybe currently facing up to
22 years in prison for conspire
conspiracy witness tampering and the
failing to register as an agent of China
Michelle was first accused I hope I'm
not saying his name wrong it's first
accused of federal crimes December of
2018. although he would eventually plead
not guilty in May of 2019 Michelle was
allegedly involved in helping Malaysian
business Mogul that's what we already
know embezzle over 4.5 billion from the
Malaysian government and use it to fund
Barack Obama's 2012 re-election campaign
what so he took he stole money and then
when he gave money like he was a big dog
to Obama Campaign well that you know
they do [__] like that just to protect
themselves from future prosecution
that's what like FTX did that
cryptocurrency exchange that went under
they were the number two donor to the
Democratic party they were just donating
money like crazy it's like leave us
alone where are you from we're gonna
give you some money like they're making
billions of dollars off these nonsense
Crypts did you invest in that [__] very
little I have some uh Bitcoin uh along
with TR asking Trump to dismiss Low's
previous crime Michelle also reportedly
worked on behalf of the Chinese
government to try to return a Chinese
dissident back from the U.S by
establishing a relationship with Steve
Bannon and Trump wow
okay before Michelle DiCaprio got to do
with anything I said decided to testify
on April 18th iconic actor Leonardo
DiCaprio was called to stand on April
3rd considering he had a previous
relationship with both Lo and Michelle
DiCaprio testified that Lo revealed to
him his plans to make donations to the
Democratic party in 2012. that that
whole donating to political party [__]
is so slippery that [__] is so slippery
because like what kind of weird deals
you guys making like why are they making
weird deals
small people like me don't they don't
get [__] but a sticker you get a sticker
that's all I ever got when I voted when
I donated to the Democratic party
their peddling influence the one article
first one we said said he didn't say he
was an informant but this everything
else is said the opposite well informant
means he had a conversation with them
and he gave them information he informed
them right you could technically say
he's an FBI informant if we went to them
with information if it's voluntarily yes
admitting that he was a deformant for
the FBI Michelle elaborated that he gave
up information about U.S hostages in
China while at the same time being a
liaison for China who was working to get
a Chinese criminal billionaire extraded
back from the U.S if this sounds like a
big ugly mess it's because it is yeah he
it seems like he just got caught up in
some [__] where he's probably trying to
make some money and they thought it
would be clean and they're going to
donate money to the Democratic party and
oh it's great working all these people
hey Leonardo's working with him oh must
be fine and that's that's one of the
ways they get people involved in these
like very shady deals as they do it with
other famous people like hey he's in
there you should be in there oh okay
about to hang out with Leo the next
thing you know you're involved in some
weird thing that's got you you know
testifying in front of Congress one
thing you can guarantee Joe Rogan I'm
never coming to an alien party with you
I love you but you can have that [__] on
your own done enough the aliens come
you're the first person I'm coming to
I'm like we're going to Atlanta if they
grab me and I'm like we're real who are
we going to tell I'm like we're gonna go
this Thursday oh found guilty on all 10
counts
in the National frog frog he was
convicted guilty on 10 counts related to
what prosecutors called a clandestine
foreign intelligence campaign scheme
funded by a wealthy Malaysian financier
to Pedal influence in the United States
see that's what I'm talking about
they're peddling influence the week-long
trial saw Witnesses like Leonardo
DiCaprio former Attorney General Jeff
sessions take the stand and testify
under oath
so that uh Malaysian guy is still at
large and he was charged as a
co-defendant in Michelle's case and
played a major role in witness testimony
and evidence presented to the jury
according to the justice department Lao
I don't know how you say it lower Lao
allegedly misappropriated over 500
million from The Sovereign wealth fund
Malaysian one Malaysian development
berhad with wire transfers to Shell
companies he and others used are owned
okay
so he's [__] man if they if they made
him he's going to jail
22 years I think it says oh my God 22
years what is he 50 [__]
he might not make it off that type of
food I think how many of those are going
on where people aren't getting arrested
though like how much of that influence
pedaling [__] is just
it's been going on for this from the
start forever this ain't nothing new I
just don't I'm still confused as to how
he's in trouble
me too like what did he he connected
people that were trying to get a
billionaire release to became friends
with Trump to try to get a guy released
no but Obama well he wasn't he was just
giving the money to him
they he tried to establish a
relationship with Steve Bannon and Trump
and Jeff sessions yeah
how weird not weird it's just what goes
on in our government but he's from the
Fugees like bro aren't you busy
Michelle 20 million in 2012 in order to
get a picture of himself with Obama and
prosecutors to Lev that allege that
Michelle funneled over 800 000 of that
money to Obama's campaign through a
number of straw donors
whoa so he made a deal where this guy
gave him 20s I'll get you a picture with
Obama you got to give me 20 million and
he said to Obama listen I'll give you
800 000. he didn't say that to Obama he
just said it he just started he just
made up all these accounts sending money
yeah but I mean they must have had some
he funneled that money through a number
of straw donors that seems to me like
that's how they would do it
well somebody donate that type of money
you want to know who it is it's not like
me who give you 20 and say no to the
next twenty dollars but they did it
through these like hidden yeah over 100
million it says so he knew what he was
doing
whoa according to prosecutors load
directed over 100 million to Michelle to
help push the government including Trump
to drop its investigation into low
uh prosecutors also say that Michelle
advocated for the extradition of Chinese
dissident guao Wendy
on behalf of the Chinese government
he said he gave him 100 million for a
media business he would start can you
imagine the Fuji they had a song in
years but they looking at him like how
is he living like that right the rest of
the group like what the [__] is he over
there doing we had a Hit album since 93.
I know right early 2000. why how is he
living like that all this time he got a
friend named Lowe who's sending him
Millions through wire he ain't telling
nobody he pulling in up in new cars and
you like I know everybody else in the
group like [__] what you up to yeah
what the [__] you doing but he didn't
tell nobody thank God he didn't work on
an international policy people like what
yeah I'm running for congress I'm
influence pedaling no he didn't say all
that he said
I got a donor what a dirty business
politics is the fact that they like no
one's mad at Obama for that no one's no
one's mad at him do you think he knows
he's getting the Democratic party
getting all that money they don't have
to give it back
no all the money that got funneled from
them imagine that got funneled to
another person that person be in trouble
it would be right but you could fall
into the Democratic party like Hey we're
having the good guys the Republicans do
the same thing everybody does everybody
everybody the idea that there's two
teams fighting against each other for
sure for for temporary control while
they all share resources if you like
look at the number of Congress people
that are inside or trading it's everyone
it's across the board it's red and blue
it's like Republican Democrat bro you
see they're all in there they're all in
cahoots they're all pretending they're
all pretending they're working for us
they hate each other they play like they
hate each other but yeah you sneak up on
one of their house and there's Mitch
mcconny at uh what's a girl name who
just left speak of the house Nancy
pelosa house getting drunk talking about
the [__] they did
I'm sorry your husband got his ass
whooped they wasn't supposed to go that
far